Indonesia is set to host Southeast Asian
leaders for the Asian Summit later on
Tuesday the political situation Myanmar
as well as disputes in the South China
Sea are likely to top the agenda
Florence Louis hasmore
East Indonesia is best known as the
gateway to the Komodo National Park
this week it's hosting leaders and
foreign ministers from the region who'll
be here for the association of Southeast
Asian Nations or asean Summit we try to
make sure that during our chairmanship
we can retain the status of asean as one
of the most dynamic regions in terms of
Economic Development
economically asean is one of the world's
fastest growing regions although growth
and prosperity vary drastically by
country there's also a gap in Human
Resources development and so so this is
the work of asean tunero the gapierre in
satacion but in the process countries
like Cambodia Laos and Myanmar they have
made themselves closer to China China
Coast Guard
China's interest
times overshadowed the blocks
its sweeping claims over much of the
South China Sea which borders many asean
nations have been a source of
disagreement and sometimes conflict
in 2012 asean foreign ministers failed
for the first time to issue a joint
communique after a standoff in the South
China Sea between China and the
Philippines the Philippines had accused
Cambodia a close Ally of China of
blocking any mention of the dispute
Indonesia as the current chair of asean
has said the group will intensify talks
with China to finalize a code of conduct
for the dispute at South China Sea
another issue that will Loom large over
the meeting is Myanmar which has
descended into Civil War since a
military coup in 2021.
Indonesia could at least publicly float
the idea of suspending Myanmar from the
block
but also suggests other asean members
that even if they don't agree on that
that they should adopt a statement that
recognizes that there is a disagreement
among the black and that the block needs
the help of
the rest of the world Indonesia says
it's working on quiet diplomacy and has
met many stakeholders including the
shadow government opposed to the coup to
try to resolve the crisis there
well we can speak now live to Florence
Louis he is in Jakarta for us Florence
what sort of pressure is being put on
the asean Nations to restart the peace
process in Myanmar
well the pressure is mostly coming from
Civil Society groups in asean countries
as well as international human rights
organizations and they've called for
asean to fully engage all parties that
have a stake in the situation in
myanmere we're seeing asean doing that
acknowledging that they've held talks
with not just the Junta but also the
shadow government and ethnic armed
organizations having said that asean's
actions still fall short of what civil
rights groups are calling for among them
tougher sanctions that really hit the
military's pockets and this would be
sanctions that Target the gas and Mining
sectors also a clearer message to the
Junta that what they're doing in Myanmar
is not just unacceptable but also
illegal so perhaps failing a suspension
of asean of of myanmar's Asian
membership then disinviting not just the
leaders from the leaders Summit but also
senior officials from meetings
throughout the year
asean though is going to find difficulty
reaching a consensus because the members
are divided Thailand for example is
known to have particularly close ties
with myanmar's military and the
situation in Myanmar is becoming more
urgent not just because the humanitarian
situation there is worsening but because
Indonesia is due to hand over asean
chairmanship to Laos later this year
this is a position that member countries
take turns holding and Laos being an
authoritarian one-party State that's
very little expectation that that
country is going to do much to put
pressure on the Junta to end violence in
Myanmar
and Florence other than Myanmar what
else is going to be on the agenda
well I think economic issues will take
top priority the theme of this year's
meeting is asean matters the epicenter
of growth and this is particularly
important as many Regional economies are
still just recovering from the impact of
the pandemic then there's also the
matter of the roadmap for membership of
Timor leste that's been pending for
years now Indonesia has also said that
it wants to tackle human trafficking
that's become a much bigger problem in
recent years
fake job recruiters lure their victims
online promising them attractive jobs
with good pay and then these victims are
then traffic to places like Myanmar and
Cambodia where they're made to perform
cyber scams and cyber crimes now
Indonesia has recently freed 20 of their
Nationals from Myanmar and Philippines
has reportedly rescued about a thousand
people from about 10 countries so this
matter is quite urgent and countries
will be sitting down to talk about how
they're going to tackle this situation
thank you for that for Laurence Louis
there for us in Jakarta